a d-class prisoner enters the chamber it
is quiet save for the subtle whipping
sounds coming from a bizarre shape in
the middle of the room upon closer
inspection it becomes clear that the
floating object isn't one entity but a
mass of smaller objects all floating and
thrashing in the air their ammunition of
various calibers and sizes spinning
around in a spherical form the d-class
becomes nervous but is ordered to
proceed by foundation personnel
slowly inch by anxious inch he advances
closer towards the mass of bullets his
heart knocks harder against his chest
with every step he takes the thumping
begins to deafen his ears he could feel
his throat tightening up as the blood
rushes to his head and sweat starts to
form on his brow the sound of the
thrashing gets louder with legs
trembling and fingertips numbing the
d-class opens his mouth in an attempt to
let in a gasp of air to calm his nerves
but before he could even take a full
breath and in the blink of an eye
countless bullets suddenly burst forth
from the mass spraying the d-class
relentlessly with ammunition and killing
him instantly the foundation personnel
watching this from safety note down the
events as they ponder the question why
does this massive living ammunition act
so volatile why are some able to
approach it safely while others are
killed what is the secret of scp-5
classified as euclid
scp-577 began as one of the most
mysterious objects in foundation custody
an animated mass of ammunition those who
are able to get close enough to it
observe that the plurality of bullets
inside were nine millimeter accompanied
by a selection of 10 millimeter and 45
caliber rounds the bullets are normally
calm moving in predictable patterns and
occasionally shifting the mass to
reflect other shapes including cats and
dogs but something else about the mass
concerns the foundation more and more
the mass is growing it is dramatically
larger than it was when it was first
acquired by the foundation and it seems
to be adding approximately a thousand
bullets per year this raises the
question can it be contained permanently
currently it is held in a standard large
containment unit but its quarters have
been reinforced with the foundation's
best steel blast shielding due to the
danger to anyone who opens the door the
entire facility is handled with remote
technology and can only be opened by
approved personnel but someone needs to
check that everything is stable the
foundation learned the hard way that
entering the containment unit was a bad
idea any foundation staff ranging from a
high-level scientist to a standard
security officer is met with immediate
hostility from
scp-577's massive bullets the second
they approached the entity the bullets
shoot out from the mass with speed of a
standard handgun aiming directly at
their target this indicates that
scp-577 is intelligent it is capable of
seeing and reacting and it hates
foundation personnel with a passion
fortunately the foundation doesn't have
to sacrifice its permanent staff
scp-577 is not the first entity to react
with hostility towards its captors after
all few of the specimens are happy to be
permanently contained in secure
facilities so it was determined that
d-class personnel would be sent into the
facility twice a year to inspect it for
any damage making sure the entity was
still secure and test
scp-577's reaction to the presence of
different people not from the
foundation's staff and that's where
things got interesting many of the
d-class personnel didn't trigger the
entity at all resulting in neutral
behavior however those d-class who were
initially foundation staff and demoted
due to broken policy were met with the
same hostility as current staff
indicating that
scp-577 was not going to be fooled
easily the same happened with some
d-class with a specific background it
was immediately sprayed with a violent
hail of bullets causing injury or death
upon investigation every single one of
those d-class was revealed to previously
be a member of law enforcement however
some d-class personnel were met with a
very different reaction these people
were the most likely to see the other
side of scp-577
when it reduced its hostile stance and
instead took on a friendly form
appearing as a dog or cat it would even
approach the d-class in a welcoming
manner this was most likely to happen
when the d-class was formerly homeless
or had spent time in the prison system
but one incident brought
scp-577's true nature into a new light
d-2812
was the latest unfortunate conscript to
be sent into
scp-577's chamber for an annual cleaning
and inspection his duties were simple
including to inspect the walls for
damage clean out any stray material left
around by the bullets firing as well as
any corpses that were left behind and
make any needed repairs to the walls he
would be wearing protective gear but
that wasn't always enough to protect
someone from the hail of bullets and no
one knew exactly how the volatile mass
of bullets would react but from the
second the d-class entered it was clear
that this would be a very different
encounter as soon as d-28126
entered
scp-577 seemed to take on a friendly
posture it shape-shifted into the form
of a large cat and would frequently
approach the d-class while he was
cleaning the d-class was confused at
first but soon seemed to appreciate the
company he would occasionally stop
cleaning to pet the cat made out of
bullets but as the work went on he
seemed to slow down he appeared to be
crying and eventually he stopped working
entirely and slumped against the wall
the foundation attempted communication
with him but the d-class didn't respond
soon
scp-577 joined him against the wall and
the d-class held him his hand was guided
into the mass of bullets and it soon
emerged holding a single bullet the
d-class held the strange entity for a
few more minutes before the staff's
insistence that he exited the chamber
grew stronger he eventually left and the
foundation took him back into custody
and examined the bullet he was holding
it was not a normal bullet the bullet
was moving almost as if it was a beating
heart as it throbbed up and down upon
closer inspection it was revealed to be
covered with blood but d-28126 had not
been hit by the bullet he was completely
uninjured but when he emerged from the
chamber his hand was covered in blood
exactly where he had inserted it into
the mass of bullets the bullet was sent
to scp facilities for testing the blood
was not a match for d-2812
but it was genetically similar like a
relative the d-class was brought back
into the interrogation chamber and the
bullet was returned to him he was
apparently linked to
scp-577 somehow and identified himself
by his name arturo rojas his interviewer
dr vanderbilt asked him to explain what
happened and arturo explained that the
massive bullets didn't just turn into a
cat it turned into a cat he knew as a
child which had a uniquely shaped tail
that he would recognize anywhere the cat
that was once helped by arturo and his
brother arturo was questioned why he
quit working and began crying and
revealed that he heard the massive
bullets say something barely audible
scp-577 had whispered i'm sorry but what
would a cat have to be sorry for arturo
became angry when dr vanderbilt
questioned this but dr vanderbilt
continued and conceded that arturo
recognized the cat somehow he prodded
arturo to share the rest of his story
and arturo eventually revealed the root
of his bond to scp-577
arturo and his deaf brother ricardo were
homeless at a young age after their
mother threw them out while they were
living on the streets they met a cat
that they gave a little of their food to
from time to time the little cat became
their constant companion they named him
duck after arturo's brother's favorite
sign language gesture but tragedy was
just around the corner duck and ricardo
were inseparable with the little cat
essentially becoming a therapy pet to
the boy but one day ricardo encountered
a police officer the deaf boy couldn't
understand the officer's orders when the
officer didn't know or didn't bother to
use sign language ultimately bullets
were fired ricardo was killed another
unarmed young man killed in a police
shooting and duck was left alone but the
cat had one more job to do he had led
arturo back to his brother the area was
swarming with police and arturo never
got a chance to say goodbye he lashed
out at the only one he could duck the
cat tried to comfort his surviving
person but arthur threw rocks at the cad
and chased him away he never saw the cat
again and was left alone with his grief
he saw on the news days later that the
officer was cleared in the shooting his
brother was blamed for threatening the
officer and the news implied that
ricardo was a gang member arturo was
left without closure until
scp-577 entered the picture dr
vanderbilt expressed his sympathies but
wasn't sure what any of this had to do
with the entity arturo explained further
why he started crying when he felt the
pulsating bullet he spent years sleeping
next to ricardo and he recognized his
brother's heartbeat the bullet was his
brother's heart or at least contained
his essence and for the first time in 10
years artoro was able to make peace not
just with the cat he had rejected out of
grief but with the brother he had lost
far too long the foundation had answers
but they only led to more questions
arturo had pulled a single bullet out of
the mass of scp-577
and it was the one containing his
brother's heart was this the bullet that
killed ricardo was every bullet in the
mass one that killed a person was the
mass growing with every new death and if
that was the case did the mass contain
the memory and pain of every life a
bullet took if so that would explain the
compassion the entity seems to hold for
those who had been homeless or
imprisoned as well as its intense
hostility for any sort of law
enforcement figure for now
scp-577 remains stable and contained
within its unit needing only standard
upkeep of its cell to avoid any breaches
but as it continues to grow foundation
authorities worry that it may get strong
enough to eventually breach containment
but this is a tricky case for the
foundation the entity's growth is out of
their control and nothing they've done
to date has stopped or slowed it in any
way it seems something on the outside is
making it grow and shows no sign of
slowing down anytime soon for another
scp with a benevolent side check out
scp-2295 the bear with the heart of
patchwork or watch this video instead